[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
d'état de santé sacré à au médecin de
famille une espèce en voie de
disparition vous savez ce médecin de
famille qu'on consultait toute sa vie
qu'on pouvait parfois déranger nuit et
jour et qui connaissait précisément
toute la famille et bien il n'existe
presque plus alors pourquoi on va
essayer de le comprendre avec évidemment
tous nos invités pourquoi et puis quel
modèle va remplacer ce précieux médecin
de famille qu'on verra bientôt plus que
dans les films et les livres on va en
parler avec vous docteur marine CRESS
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous merci
vous êtes médecin général iste à
Marseille vous avez fondé l'association
guérir en mer vous nous direz tout à
l'heure enfin guérir en mer on a compris
l'idée qui accompagne les soignant
victime de Burnout je me permets de dire
que vous en avez eu un mais pendant vos
études et maintenant vous aidez les
médecins jeunes et moins jeunes
peut-être à combiner la vie
professionnelle avec la vie personnelle
et vous avez été chargé par le ministère
de la Santé en mars 2023 dériger de
rédiger un rapport sur la santé des
soignants Frédéric Valtou on est très
heureux de vous recevoir député horizon
de senemand rapporteur de la proposition
de loi sur l'accès aux soins qui vient
d'être adopté en première lecture au
Sénat elle est ressorti un peu amendé
pour ne pas dire pas mal amendé
d'ailleurs mais vous nous direz quelles
sont vos propositions précisément
pour faire muter ce ce ce métier de de
médecin que vous connaissez parfaitement
bien euh bonjour Arnaud bontemp merci
d'être avec nous vous avez été en charge
de l'organisation territoriale des soins
à la CPAM la Caisse Primaire d'Assurance
Maladie de sainene Saint-Denis en pleine
crise du covid alors vous avez dû voir
évidemment ce que c'est que la santé
sousension et vous avez coffondé le
collectif nos services publics pour
mettre la question du service public au
cœur du débat euh politique merci Maria
bsova d'être avec nous économiste chargé
de mission santé à l'UFC Que Choisir
vous avez participé à l'écriture de
plusieurs rapports de l'association sur
les déserts médicaux et enfin docteur am
docteur amamond vous connais bien euh
vous avez 50 ans
d'exercice bel anniversaire 50 ans de
médecine général au sein de votre
cabinet à clamar dans la région
parisienne également président d'honneur
de la Fédération des médecins de France
vous portez depuis très longtemps la
parole syndicale des médecins généralist
continuez de consulter d'ailleurs mais
je consulte à temps plein à temps plein
dans un groupe de 5 médecins
généralistes qui a été créé en 52 à
l'époque où l'ordre des médecins
considérait que c'était pas bien de se
regrouper et c'était un médecin alors on
y reviendra tout à l'heure mais c'est
intéressant le regroupement évidemment
ma docteur docteur Crest le médecin de
famille il a disparu euh ça vous parle
vous le médecin de famille ou bon c'est
c'est le moyen-âge alors moi je suis ni
trop jeune ni trop vieille je représente
la la tranche d'ge intermédiaire et la
la grande population des femmes médecins
parce que ce sont des métiers quand même
qui sont très féminisés he h il y a 10
ans je faisais une émission dont le
titre était enquête de santé la fin du
médecin de famille donc c'était une des
premières émission c'était il y a 10 ans
moi je suis toujours médecin généraliste
et je pense être un médecin de famille
alors si la question c'est il n'y a plus
de médecin de famille je pense que la
réponse est il y en a mais c'est pas
ceux qui étaient là avant et ce ne sera
pas ceux qui seront là demain
c'est-à-dire que c'est un métier qui est
en cours d'évolution on est exactement
un tournant à un changement qui est en
train de se construire avec les différ
différents acteurs et la différence par
rapport à avant c'est peut-être que dans
ces acteurs là il y a pas que les
médecins il y a pas que les soignants il
y a les patients aussi et puis il y a
les générations les générations qui
évoluent même moi j'ai du mal parfois à
communiquer à comprendre des confrères
qui sont un tout petit peu plus jeunes
ou un petit peu plus âgés parce que
chacun intègre en fait sa profession
dans son quotidien de manière différente
avec des nécessités des besoins qui
évoluent avec ceux de la société c'est
ça qui fait que c'est un médecin qui
change famille un médecin de famille
d'ailleurs c'était en général un homme
et alors c'est un un modèle en voie de
disparition il s'est énormément féminisé
comme vous l'avez souligné euh dès le
début alors les médecins ne sont rien
sans les patients et si c'est compliqué
d'être médecin aujourd'hui c'est très
compliqué d'être patient quel est le le
le
ratio le le nombre de médecins
généralistes aujourd'hui qui disent non
à des nouveaux patients alors
aujourd'hui c'est près de la moitié des
médecins généralistes qui refusent les
nouveaux patients euh donc donc c'est
particulièrement compliqué de trouver un
médecin traitant sachant que il y a eu
des annonces qui ont été faites par les
autorités cette année pour dire qu'on
allait trouver des des médecins traitant
aux patients notamment au patients en
infection de longue durée sans médecin
traitant et la première chose qu'a fait
la sécurité sociale céit écrire aux
patients qui n'avait pas de médecin
traitant comme si c'était aux patients
de se débrouiller alors que les patients
sont aujourd'hui dans un problème
systémique de pénuerie et donc c'est pas
souvent souvent c'est pas faute de
volonté du patient qu'on trouve pas de
médecin traitant c'est fautes
d'accessibilité selon où on habite selon
euh est-ce que les médecins sont proches
de leur départ en retraite est-ce qu'ils
ont déjà beaucoup de de patientelle vous
avez déjà euh résumé ou ou cité quelques
causes évidemment du de de de la
démographie euh médicale en grande
pénurie euh on s'arrête quelques
instants pour euh un petit point
d'histoire pourquoi les généralistes
sont-ils euh de moins en moins nombreux
explication de
texte
en France une personne sur tris vit dans
un désert médical 6 millions de
personnes n'ont pas de médecin traitant
et leur recherche pourrait bien durer
car la pénurie a empiré ces dernières
années la densité de médecin généraliste
est passée de 153 pour 100000 habitants
en 2012 à 140 pour 100000 en
2021 pourquoi principalement parce que
nous ne mon pas assez de médecins et
cela remonte aux années 70 à cette
époque les cabinets médicaux poussaient
comme des champignons et les bandéfag de
médecine étaient remplis de futur
généralistes mais c'est aussi à cette
époque qu'on a découvert le trou de la
Sécu pour le combler et sous l'influence
des médecins libéraux le gouvernement a
choisi de limiter les dépenses en
limitant le nombre de médecins le
numérus closus faisait son apparition de
8500 places offertes aux étudiants en
1977 on est descendu jusqu'à 3500
admissions en
[Musique]
1993 le nombre de nouveaux médecins a
drastiquement baissé et dans le même
temps la demande de soins elle a
augmenté car la population vieillit les
baby boomers nés après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale ont atteint le 3e âge dans les
années 2010 on parle de papibom
et pour ne rien arranger les
généralistes eux aussi vieillissent
comme tout le monde près de 50 % des
médecins inscrits à l'ordre ont plus de
60 ans ainsi depuis 2020 il y a
davantage de départ à la retraite que de
nouveaux arrivants heureusement le
numérus closus a augmenté au début des
années 2000 et en 2020 il a été remplacé
par un numérus apertus c'est-à-dire un
quota minimum de place fixé par les facs
de médecine en fonction des besoins du
territoire mais ces décisions ne
devraient porter leur fruit qu'à partir
de
[Musique]
2030 alors si on comprend bien nos bon
temps en
2030 essaie de voir ce qui qui peut nous
donner un peu d'espoir en 2030 ce sera
le pic de la pénuriie de médecins liés à
cette logique du numérus closus on
commencera à avoir un petit peu moins de
pénurie à partir de 2030 ça ce serait
frèire abstraction de l'évolution
continue dans le même temps des besoins
de santé on le reportage à l'instant
mentionna la question du vieillissement
de la population dans les 10 dernières
années c'est 12 % de plus de 75 ans en
plus dans dans la population dans le
même temps ce qui est encore plus
frappant c'est l'évolution du nombre ce
qu'on appelle les affections longue
durée en clair les maladies chroniques
et les cancer dans les 10 dernières
années c'est plus de plus 30 %
aujourd'hui c'est un patient sur 6 donc
en fait c'est ça ça l'enjeu auquel il
faut qu'on réponde c'est pour ça qu'il y
a une crise de système de santé
aujourd'hui en particulier de la
médecine de ville c'est que on a un
système qui a été inchangé dans ces
modalités alors que les évolutions
pathologiques elles sont
épidémiologiques son sont très fortes et
donc en effet le médecin le modèle d'un
professionnel de santé qui serait un
médecin isolé ne correspond plus à la
prise en charge des patients chroniques
qui nécessitent un travail en équipe
entre différentes professions et donc
c'est ça qu' faut que notre modèle
aujourd'hui arrive à inciter vous nous
direz quelles sont les solutions qu'on
peut mettre en place raisonnablement
aujourd'hui évidemment au bénéfice de
tous il y a moins de médecins et il y a
un problème de répartition on va
regarder cette carte vous allez regarder
attentivement toute cette carte de
France est en fait myé par des petits
points blancs et ces petits points
blancs c'est là où il y a pratiquement
aucun ou presque aucun médecin et
ensuite vous voyez que plus c'est foncé
plus il y a de médecins disponiblebl au
service des patients on voit bien que le
sud au sens large est assez bien doté
avec les parties littorales où il y a
quand même là une démographie assez
positive et puis plus on monte vers le
nord et surtout autour autour de la
capitale et ainsi que le centre de la
France et bien là il y a une pinurie de
médecin caractérisée je voudrais qu'on
aille tout de suite dans la Creuse c'est
un des départements les moins dotés la
Creuse à chatelu malvallé écoutez ce
couple de médecin 66 et 64 ans il
voudrait ce couple de médecin prendre sa
retraite il ne trouve pas de successeurs
et vous entendrez dans la foulée un
patient évidemment qui est
[Musique]
pénalisé on a mis des annonces un peu
partout et et bon je pense qu'on on n
pas les seuls à à
chercher ça fait 36 ans que je suis là
que je connais des familles depuis deux
trois génération euh donc c'est ce sont
plus des amis que des patients donc
c'est très difficile de les laisser
tomber on a soigné les parents les
maintenant les enfants maintenant on
soigne les petits- enfants donc ça fait
un peu mal au cœur quoi il y a des gens
qui seront plus suivis qui vont plus
arrêter leur traitement euh donc ça va
être vraiment dramatique je pense oui
j'ai proposé à la commune de de
travailler 2 jours par semaine comme
salarié avec ma femme pour essayer de de
dépanner un petit peu en attendant de
trouver un successeur ça m'inquiète
parce que il va falloir retrouver un un
médecin et les médecins ils sont
surchargés déserves médicales ça c'est
c'est c'est pire en pire alors je sais
pas où qu'on va aller comme ça où qu'on
va qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire
bon qu'est-ce qu'on va faire c'est bien
poser comme question il s'agit de
trouver des réponses Frédéric Valtou
vous avez présenter une proposition de
loi soumis une proposition de loi au
Sénat avec un certain nombre donc de de
mesures que vous préconisez tout de
suite je va posé la question qui fâche
parce qu'on tourne autour en France
depuis des années d'abord la
coercition
l'obligation faite au médecins par
exemple à la sortie de leurs études de
s'installer là où les patients on besoin
vous n'yêtes pas favorable j'y suis pas
favorable dans la période actuelle j'y
suis pas favorable la période où
effectivement on a si peu de médecins
chaque année vous donniez les chiffres à
Jea dire imaginer répartir là où il y a
des besoins par contre que dans l'avenir
dans les années qui redeviendront fast
c'est peut-être un grand mot en tout cas
meilleur dans les années 30 32 35 quand
effectivement plus de jeunes auront été
formés qu'il y ait un système qui veille
à ne pas reproduire les erreurs du passé
de concentration
euh et de juste répartition par quel par
quel moyen je pense que c'est à la
profession d'y réfléchir c'est pas après
nous les parlementaires on peut avoir
des idées mais il y a beaucoup de
professions qui se sont pris par la main
et qui ont imaginé des systèmes je pense
au pharmaciens je pense à d'autres ont
imaginé d'eux même des systèmes pour
répondre au à l'intérêt général et au
besoins des des des des Français donc on
pourrait attendre effectivement que dans
les années qui qui qui nous nous a qui
nous qui nous nous éloigne de ce cette
époque de 2035 que j'évoquais on puisse
voir émerger des propositions pour
queeffectivement on on dise bah on va
pas reproduire ce qu'on a vécu par le
passé il y a un besoin effectivement
qu'on soit pas tous concentrés parce que
là on parle des généralistes mais si on
regardeit les cartes pour les
spécialistes c'est encore pire la
concentration des spécialistes c'est
encore pire que la question la question
des
généralistes et donc voilà c'est un
système à à inventer je pense que pour
l'instant c'est pas le sujet et la
coerition on sait que malheureusement
c'est un sujet qui qui qui fâche et si
on veut que cette profession évolue et
comme toutes les professions elle doit
évoluer il faut qu'on arrive à emmener
avec nous les d'accord donc je pas de
coerition dans un système hyper tendu
pour l'instant il y a un manque criant
de de médecin entre guétir la rareté ça
rendra personne rich pour éclairer nos
débats si vous voulez bien c'est
toujours intéressant de se comparer aux
autres regardez cette cette carte qu'on
a préparé justement pour vous montrer ce
qui se passe ailleurs au Pays-Bas et en
Belgique à l'instart de la France les
médecins sont libres de s'installer où
ils le souhaitent il y a des mesures
incitatives on va parler de l'Allemagne
le Danemark et la Norvège là il y a des
mesures
coercitives par exemple au Danemarc et
au Norvège pour prendre cet exemple les
médecins généralistes sont libéraux mais
ils doivent passer un contrat avec les
autorités local qui régulent la
distribution des cabinets sur le
territoire en Grande-Bretagne et en
Espagne les systèmes de santé sont
publics les généralistes britanniques
sont installés sont salariés par la
National Health Service
NHS et et donc leur installation est
parfaitement régulée en fonction des des
besoins les généralistes espagnols eux
ils sont salariés par les régions
autonomes et ce sont elles les régions
qui décident des des effectifs de
médecins à former et leur installation
donc on voit bien que là il y a des pays
qui ont adopté des systèmes qui sont
extrêmement
différents la coercition est-ce que ça
marche est-ce que ça permet à ses pays
puisque on dit que ça existe est-ce que
ça permet au pays aux patients d'être
mieux soigné est-ce que ça permet
d'avoir des systèmes qui fonctionnent
mieux alors il y a un rapport de
l'adresse donc le service statistique du
ministère de la Santé qui dit que les
mesures coeritives sur l'installation
combinées à d'autres mesures peuvent ont
contribué dans d'autres pays à améliorer
l'accès aux soins c'est sûr que c'est
pas la coerc seul mais ça peut être un
élément d'une politique qui marche bien
et cite plusieurs exemples mais par
contre là où je partage pas l'analyse de
Monsieur Valtou c'est que pour nous pour
l'UFC Que Choisir c'est parce que la
peignuriie est particulièrement intense
aujourd'hui que c'est le moment de
prendre des mesures contraignantes sur
la liberté d'installation puisque donc
ce que vous montriez sur la démographie
médicale et le cas de la Creuse qui
était présenté dans le reportage sont
assez symptomatiques puisque ce qu'on a
montré dans notre étude sur l'accès aux
soins qui est paru cette année c'est que
les départements où les généralistes
sont les plus âgés sont aussi les moins
denses c'est-à-dire que dans la vague de
départ en retraite qui qui qui n'en est
qu'à ses débuts ça va être les
départements déjà les plus démunis qui
vont perdre le plus de médecins suite au
départ en retraite et donc pour nous
c'est pour ça qu'il faut réguler
maintenant pour gérer la pénurie et par
ailleurs ce que défend l'FC que choisir
ce n'est pas la coer au sens de prendre
un un jeune médecin et lui dire vous
allez dans la Creuse nous ce qu'on
défend c'est fermer l'Inst installation
dans les zones les mieux dotées donc par
exemple sur le littoral dans est-ce
qu'il y a des autres qui sont surdoté ou
elles sont simplement mieux doté que les
autres al il y a des zones qui sont
mieux dotés que les autres mais dans une
situation de pénurie c'est enfin dans
tous les cas de pénurie c'est quand il y
a une pénurie qu'on rationne et donc
pour nous il faut envoyer les patients
dans les zones donc on déshabille Paul
pour habiller Jacques vous dites c'est
un moindre mal on ne peut pas faire
autrement il y a une pénurie on va dans
10 ans de pénurie voilà vous auriez
accepté pén à la sortie de vos études et
etaremment vous allez avoir la parole
dans une seconde mais vous auriez
accepté vous docteur qu'on vous dise à
la fin de vos études ben il vaudrait
mieux aller là euh avec plus ou moins de
enfin pardon non vous allez où vous
voulez sauf les ares les mieux dotés
voilà merci d'avoir reformulé la
question ce qui est compliqué c'est que
il faut pas enfin à mon sens he les il
faut on doit c'est la faute a c'est la
faute a comprendre que quand vous faites
médecine ou notutre profession de soin
d'ailleurs au départ vous le faites
plutôt par vocation et par élan
aujourd'hui cet élan il est en train de
se se tarir c'estd que les jeunes n'ont
pas envie d'y aller parce qu'ils voient
ceux qui sont sur le terrain qui s'en
vont qui arrêtent et du coup ils ont pas
envie d'y aller ils sont accompagnés par
des professionnels de santé qui sont en
souffrance et donc du coup ils ont même
pas ni envie d'y aller puis plus envie
de
rester obliger quelqu'un avec une
contrainte comme ça ça ne marchera pas
et je pense encore moins en France parce
que ça correspond pas à la personnalité
du français et ça correspond pas à un
besoin c'estd que si on vous force à
faire un métier là vous avez pas envie
de le faire vous NZ pas on va pas y
aller on n'ira pas moi on m'aurait fait
réfléchir sur comment est-ce qu'on peut
répondre à un besoin et que ça vienne de
la part des professionnels de santé
eux-mêmes il faut comprendre que c'est
des femmes des familles sur dans des
zones où il y a pas d'attractivité il y
a pas d'attractivité dans les métiers
sur les territoires c'est une politique
qui est qui est tellement
multifactorielle que il faut pas juste
centrer sur on leur dit qu'il faut pas
aller là mais par contre ils peuvent
aller là mais attendez ça dépend pas
uniquement de ce facteur là ça dép alors
docteur parce que vous bouillez depuis
tout à l'heure etou nor très heureux
d'entendre monsieur valt dire qu'il est
contre la coerition maintenant non ça
pas toujours été son cas euh vous avez
parlé vous avez
parl on essaie d'être constructif vous
AZ parlé du danemar vous AZ parlé du
Danemark je peux parler du Danemark j'y
suis allé justement et au Danemark si un
médecin veut s'installer dans une région
on lui dit c'est à tel endroit mais dans
la région il choisit la région où il
veut s'installer et le médecin danois il
travaille pas dans les mêmes conditions
que le médecin de français si vous
voulez permettre aux jeunes de de de
s'installer il faut qu'il bosse avec un
secrétariat présentiel avec des au
correct et faire découvrir et faire
découvrir aux internes cette cette
médecine qui est passionnante à exercer
et au Danemark la différence c'est que
les médecins danois collaborent avec
l'hôpital c'estàdire qu'ils vont
régulièrement à l'hôpital et il y a une
vraie collaboration avec l'hôpital
tandis qu'ici avec l'hôpital il y a
maintenant une concurrence avec
l'hôpital qui fait des choses qui
pourraient être parfaitement en fait en
ville et et si on veut donc c'est un
système qui vous qui vous paraît plutôt
positif mais mais vous avez parlé du
Danemark vous avez parlé également de la
Creuse creuse je suis allé à Royer de
vassivère ou qui qui est un désert de
population mais mais à Royer de
Vassivière les médecins ont fait venir
des internes les les maires ont logé les
internes il y a eu une prime pour que
les internes puissent venir dans la
Creuse et quand j'ai visiter ce cabinet
il y avait il y avait quatre médecins
qui avaient deux collaborateurs qui
étaient d'anciens internes c'est-à-dire
des gens qui étaient prêt à venir
s'installer parce qu'ils ont découvert
une médecine de de de de de premier
recours qui est passionnante à exercer
pour pourvu qu'on donne l'habitude aux
internes d'aller dans ces zones dans de
bonnes conditions et là ils y allaient
dans de bonnes conditions et dans la SER
aller dans la Creuse vous seriez allé
vous installer si vous aviez eu la
promesse d'avoir des bons collaborateurs
c'est aussi simple que ça non c'est pas
aussi simple c'est que la problématique
c'est que les les futurs médecins
généralistes sont formés à l'hôpital
dans un dans un système universitaire
d'accord pour toutes les problématiques
aussi de main d'œuvre à l'hôpital de les
internes qui vont aider à ça aider à ça
et ça c'est la problématique de la
formation initiale la formation continue
juste à la sortie de l'internat euh si
on arrive à revaloriser ce métier au
sens large redonner du sens redonner
envie de le faire les maîtres de stage
sur les terrain transmettent une passion
d'un métier encore faut-il qu'elle
existe et une fois qu'elle est transmise
si elle arrive à être transmise mais je
pense que les gens ils ont envie de
faire de la médecine ilst envie de faire
du soin finalement quel que soit
l'endroit à condition comme le disait le
docteur Ramon que ils puissent y vivre
confortablement avec leur famille une
attractivité aussi pour les conjoints
pour avoir des professions et cetera
c'est la répartition sur le territoire
qui compte avec l'or
par territoire alors pour bien
comprendre ce qu'est l'exercice de la
médecine aujourd'hui et vous l'avez dit
il suffit pas de faire des incitation il
faut rendre une attractivité au métier
il y a beaucoup de jeunes médecins
aujourd'hui qui cherchent un bon
équilibre pour ne pas craquer pour pas
avoir de Burnout je voudrais qu'on aille
qu'on suive alors un médecin à Marseille
un un jeune médecin que généraliste qui
a trouvé une solution pour pouvoir
combiner son plaisir sa vocation avec sa
vie personnelle c'est reportage de
Marianne
[Musique]
cazou nager pendant sa journée de
travail c'est commun pour un athlète
moins pour un médecin généraliste mais
c'est le seul moyen que thier nietetto a
trouvver pour relâcher enfin la
pression de covid notamment ça a
été très éprouvant physiquement et
surtout mentalement je pense que depuis
cette période là je vois les choses
différemment et je prends plus le temps
de décompresser de de de gérer les
choses et mettre des limites que je
faisais peut-être pas avant une décision
nécessaire pour tenir le rythme car les
journées du docteur nietto ressemblent
souvent à un numéro
d'équilibriste ouverture du cabinet à
8h45 ce matin j'ai 12 consultations qui
sont prévues quelques minutes avant que
le flot ininterrompu des patients
n'arrive bonjour monsieur jeune ou plus
âgé en bonne santé ou souffrant de
plusieurs maladies chroniques les
patients se suivent et les consultations
s'enchaînent alors on a la prise de sent
de contrôle on a dit la Mamo la colon on
est bon
euh vous en estes tout au niveau
vaccination covid gripe en tant que
médecin traitant Thierry nietetto doit
faire de la prévention prendre le temps
d'expliquer elle est nickel la tension
107 59 en langage courant on dit 10 5 et
de rassurer les patients qui en ont
besoin quand on manque vraiment beaucoup
de fer on a fini par faire des anémies
on les globules rouges qui baisse et
c'est là qu'on a des symptômes he qu'on
est fatigué qu'on est essoufflé c'est
pas le cas du tout hein vous c'est juste
les réserves en faire qui soit un petit
peu basse mais ça s'explique par rapport
à votre alimentation mais ce faisant le
temps file alors il faut gérer les
priorités et ça peut être intéressant de
faire la kiné euh là il y a prééducation
du Rachi lombaire OK et après on
s'occupera du problème et matau sans
urgence ouais bonne journée à bientôt
merci à ce qui est difficile à vivre
pour ce médecin très investi on est tout
le temps torturé entre essayer de faire
de la qualité et donc là si je veux
faire la qualité je garde tout le monde
longtemps et j'ai 2hures de retard et je
rentre à 10h le soir et essayer de faire
quelque chose de de viable hein avec des
temps de consultation limité et souvent
on n pas le temps on est obligé d'être
directif poser juste les questions qu'il
faut pour pouvoir les les soigner plus
rapidement et oui c'est ça qui est qui
est dommage en fait car aux consultation
s'ajoute plus de 5 heur par semaines de
tâches
administratives il a plus rien qui
marche tietto s'y attelle pendant sa
pause
déjeuner avant de commencer sa tournée
des visites à
domicile du coup j'ai vu vous toussez un
petit peu sont essentiels pour ces
patients âgés qui ne peuvent plus se
déplacer jusqu'au cabinet il vous ont
remis quand même un petit peu
d'attaque c'est très compliqué il y en a
qui veulent
plus venir à domicile c'est vrai j'ai
subi opération quand
même de de la
coltbr de du genou de la
prothèse thier se voit comme un médecin
de famille il tient ses moments
privilégiés avec des personnes qu'il
suit sur le long terme comme cette
patiente dont il a accompagné la mère
jusqu'à la fin de ses
jours mais il a décidé de ne plus
prendre de nouveaux patients qui n'ont
pas la capacité de se rendre au cabinet
car une visite n'est pas rentable pour
un médecin libéral elle prend trois à
quatre fois plus de temps qu'une
consultation pour seulement 10 € de plus
benah du coup 35 s'il vous plaît en
faisant ce choix Thierry nietetto ne
peut s'empêcher de culpabiliser on
essaie de le trouver des solutions mais
ils nous disent est-ce que vous
connaissez un confrère qui fait des
vites à domicile malheureusement non
parce que la plupart ils sont dans le
même cas que moi il y en a qui en font
plus du tout d'ailleurs nous on fait
quand même ce boulot pour pour aider les
gens pour les soigner et pas pour
refuser des soins donc ouais c'est c'est
un vrai éche mais pour lui il n'y a
qu'avec cet équilibre fragile qu'il peut
ten sur la
[Musique]
durée bon c'est pas le seul métier qui
qui est sous stress on va pas non
plus dramatiser mais quand même c'est
pas un métier comme les autres vous
aussi d'ailleurs est-ce que vous allez à
la piscine docteur Crest pour moi je je
fais du bateau moi jeis du bateau du
bateau mais c'est vital pour vous c'est
pas seulement un loisir comme tout le
monde c'est l'équilibre de la vie quelle
que soit la profession dans la police
les instites voyez c'est partout c'est
un équilibre Vie privée vie
professionnelle sport santé alimentation
santé sommeil gestion des émotions le le
le métier du soin il subit un certain
nombre de violences en particulier
actuellement des violences par le métier
qui est difficile avec ce qu'on vit les
institutions qui mettent des pressions
extrêmes sur les médecins généralistes
comme si le médecin en fait finalement
était à la cause de toutes ces
problématiques duissement de la
population et cetera de du mal-être en
fait de la société et toutes ces ces
pressions font que bah il a vraiment
besoin de prendre soin de lui parce
qu'en fait si le médecin va pas bien ou
l'infirmière ça marche pour tous les
professionnels de santé demain il y aura
plus personne pour s'occuper des gens
alors quoi qu'on en pense voilà les
jeunes médecins ils veulent pas
travailler comme vous avez travaillé
pendant des années docteur Ramon dire 50
he par semaine c'est fini mais je vous
dire c'est c'est normal parce que les
35h sont les 35 HE sont passées par là
moi quand je me suis arrivé quand je me
suis installé j'étais on avait encore
l'image du du du du médecin généraliste
qui était taillable et corvable à merci
qui se levait la la nuit et cetera les
médecins que j'ai remplacé étaient tous
travaillaient tous dans une grande
maison avait du personnel à la maison et
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait on permet au
médecins de se de se travailler ensemble
moi je je je milite pour des des groupes
monodisciplinaires et je peux vous dire
que les cinq médecins généralis qu'on
est actuellement il faudra sans doute
qu'on soit 6 ou se pour assurer la
continuité des soins mais il faut avoir
les moyens d'avoir un secrétariat
c'estàd qu'il faut pouvoir le payer ce
secrétariat c'est ça qui nous décharge
des tâches administratives c'est ça qui
nous permetavoir d'aller faire des
visites à domicile chez les personnes
âgées qui n'ont plus les moyens de se
déplacer parce que ça aussi si vous
voulez on parle du maintien à domicile
et personnes âgées on parle de du
vieillissement de la population mais on
ne peut maintenir les gens à domicile
qu'avec des infirmiers et des kinés qui
puissent se déplacer or actuellement les
infirmiers se déplacent pour 2,50 € 2,75
€ monsieur Brown a tweeté qu'il avait
augmenté de de 10 % le déplacement des
infirmiers 2,75 € 2,50 € pour le kiné
donc c'est c'est des professions qui
sont capitales en plus alors est-ce que
le salariat je vous pose une question je
la pose à Arna bontan tiens qu'on l'a
pas entendu depuis tout à l'heure est-ce
que le salariat dans les centres de
santé c'est un bon moyen d'attirer des
médecins dans les déserts médicaux ce
qu'on constate y compris avec ce
reportage c'est que le paiement à l'acte
met les professionnels de santé dans
dans un système d'injonction
contradictoire le médecin qu'on voit là
il nous parle de qualité il nous dit
j'ai pas le temps de la faire dans ce et
en fait tout temps de coordination toute
réunion qui va faire avec une infirmière
un quiiné à côté sera du temps qu'il ne
sera pas payé en consultation donc qui
sera un manque à gagner c'est une
injonction contradictoire contenue dans
le système c'est pas la faute à à Paul
ou Jacques mais du coup on a besoin de
repenser ce système 1 qui est
monoprofessionnel c'est ce qu'a dit
Jean-Paul Hanon à l'envers c'est-à-dire
que je pense qu'on n' sortira pas si on
ne considère que les médecins on a
besoin de considérer les infirmières les
kinés et toutes les professions qui sont
autour et on a besoin de penser autre
chose que le paiement à l'AE le salariat
dans les centres de santé le permet
c'est une et si c'est un modèle le
salarié de plus en le salariat qui est
de plus en plus attractif pour les
médecins c'est parce que il y a une
meilleure conciliation entre équilibre
pro euh et euh et vie personnel c'est
parce que il y a un un environnement
pluriprofessionnel une capacité à mieux
prendre en soin les patients c'est
intéressant ce que vous dites mais
factuellement est-ce que ça aide le
salariat à attirer les médecins alors
euh nous ce qu'on a observé en tant que
patient c'est que l'exercice groupé que
ce soit en maison pleur professionnelle
ou en maison de santé public salarié
c'est apprécié à la fois par les
patients et par les professionnels et
effectivement si le médecin
d'aujourd'hui veut travailler 35 he mais
que par contre il est déchargé
complètement des tâches administratives
ça permet de de limiter les dégâts sur
la sur le nombre d'heures à effectuer
vraiment des des ma question c'est si on
salarie les médecins euh une
collectivité par exemple est-ce que ça
permet d'attirer plus de médecins est-ce
que c'est efficace en terme de bah de de
réponse à la demande de soins alors
plusieurs choses déjà on a autorisé
récemment les collectivités à salariés
des médecins février 2022 je crois donc
on est au balbuement de ce système donc
on n pas encore de recul si
si ça se faisait avant mais il également
il me semble la fonction territoriale
pour l'employer ça se faisait de de
enfin ça a des expérimentations qui ont
été faites mais ça se fait et on voit
qu'effectivement les les médecins son
qui salari les professionnels de santé
on on a suffisamment de recul bien sû
c'est un modèle qui effectivement c'est
vous démarrez votre journée que vous
voyez un patient vous soyez en réunion
de coordination vous savez que de toute
façon vous serez payé puisque vous
connaissez le revenu que vous allez
avoir pendant le le mois ça n'incite pas
forcément effectivement à y consacrer
plus de temps que le temps qui est dans
le contrat que vous avez signé donc
c'est un autre modèle que
effffectivement le le modè modè libéral
mais on voit qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
modèle qui intéresse beaucoup les
intéresse beaucoup les jeunes faut bien
voir que dans cette crise qu'on vit
aussi du du médecin de de de de famille
puisque c'est le thème de la de
l'émission C'est aussi que pendant très
longtemps il faut le dire la médecine
générale a été profondément déconsidérée
dans les études de médecine et par les
jeunes médecins où on faisait ceux qui
faisaent médecins généraliste oui il y
avait le le spécialiste et on a mis en
avant la médecine de spécialité et du
coup le généraliste c'est celui qui
avait un peu raté ses études qui é pas
capable de faire chirurgie c'est
toujours le cas ou pas ah je sais pas si
c'est cas faut demander au médecins mais
je pense pas parce qu' aujourd'hui non
non mais je pense pas parce qu'jourd'hui
la médecine générale est reconnue comme
étant une spécialité donc il y a un
voilà et et la médecine générale il y a
aussi de plus en plus de médecins
généraux qui travaillent dans des
systèmes ouverts avec des hôpitaux dans
des programmes de recherche et donc il y
a une dimension universitaire qui peut
continuer à à rester il y a de plus en
plus de cabinets qui s'ouvre à former et
accueillir des jeunes internes donc on
voit que ça évolue et effectivement la
médecine générale d'équipe permet
effectivement de structurer des cabinets
qui accueillent des jeunes internes qui
ont un rôle d'accompagnement de la des
jeunes générations en tout cas le
salariat ça répond euh un des besoins
sur certains territoires par pas
question de généraliser comme en
Grande-Bretagne évidemment on en est pas
du tout là euh pas du tout là il y a il
y a le salariat je voudrais qu'on
s'arrête sur quelque chose qui se
développe beaucoup alors là dans la
pratique et pour le patient et pour le
médecin c'est la télémédecine euh
regardez ce ce
[Musique]
reportage
et si votre nouveau médecin tenait dans
cette cabine stthoscope connecté
thermomètre prise de tension automatique
un dispositif digne des astronautes
pourtant nous sommes dans une petite
commune de lesson tout ce qu'il y a plus
normal une cabine de téléconsultation a
été installée ici pour assurer la
continuité des soins dans cette zone
sousdotée alors je vais vous demander de
vous désinfecter les mains ici pas de
personnel médical l'accueil est assuré
par un employé de la
mairie mon médecin n'est pas toujours
disponible à me prendre il est à 25 km
de chez moi donc je j'ai été aussi loin
parce qu'avant j'avais mon médecin sur
mcy mais il est parti à la retraite donc
après j'ai beaucoup de mal à en trouver
un bonjour et bienvenue veuillez insérer
votre carte vitale dans le lecteur situé
face à vous donc voilà là vous allez
être connecté je vous laisse en fait le
médecin c'est lui mais il est à des
centaines de kilomètres de la ine je
suis le médecin téléconsultant bonjour
Docteur qu'est-ce que je vais pouvoir
faire pour vous j'ai un peu de tension
en ce moment on va pouvoir avec la
cabine utiliser certains outils pour
pouvoir observer votre tension notamment
et puis examiner d'autres choses si
besoin les instruments médicaux doivent
être manipulés par le patient lui-même
et ce n'est pas toujours si facile si
vous êtes pas à l'aise peut-être que
c'est votre bras qui est pas assez
appliqué ou en tout cas posé le long du
du
dispositif ça nécessite petite petite
manipe au départ ok ça me paraît bien
les données sont reçues en temps réel
sur l'ordinateur du médecin le patient
devient donc son propre infirmier
suivant les directives du lointain
docteur vous mettez votre index collé
contre la clavicule en haut la main à
plat écoute du cœur prise de température
le conduit auditif et même la gorge
peuvent être ausculté vous allez bien
tirer la langue et faites
à et ben voilà parfait on a tout c'est
bon c'est bon pour moi la gorge Scine
pas de souci je suis en train de rédiger
un compte-rendu pour votre médecin
traitant celui-ci va sortir juste devant
vous vous allez avoir à nouveau quelques
petits instant d'attente un simple
compte-rendu le rôle de surveillance lui
est laissé au médecin traitant on est
dans du premier recours c'est une
consultation plutôt au contexte comme
SOS médecin ou ou peut-être les urgences
où le le patient choisit enfin un
créneau prend un rendez-vous et tombe
sur un médecin qui qui sera celui dispo
au moment venu mais pas pas celui qui
l'aura choisi vous revyez votre médecin
traitant la semaine prochaine pas de
panique et on voit comment ça peut
s'améliorer mais la télémédecine ne
s'adresse pas qu'au consultation
d'urgence parmi les nombreuses
applications qui se sont développées ces
dernières années certaines se sont
spécialisées dans le télésuivi des
patients souffrant de maladie chronique
comme Nicole insuffisante cardiaque à 78
ans elle se connecte
régulièrement ainsi tous les lundis
c'est la même routine
alors là c'était
45 600 ce
matin alors est-ce que je tousse pas du
tout
terminé voilà ça me permet de de de voir
l'évolution de ma maladie et de gérer un
peu de voir où j'en suis quoi c'est
rassurant parce que on se
sent pas tout
seul mais pas de chance ce jour-là
Nicole réalise qu'elle vient de se
tromper dans l'une de ses réponse j'ai
mis 45 800 et c'est c'est 46 800 et 46
600 mais c'est pas possible de revenir
en arrière ben non j'essaye mais ça ça
marche
pas contactez-nous ils nous disent mais
je sais pas qui est-ce qu'il faut que je
contacte alors elle admet avec le
numérique il lui manque quand même un
peu de contact humain dans les question
on demande répondre presque par oui et
par non quoi c'est c'est ça il y a pas
de de de dialogue possible quoi c'est ça
avec la télémédecine la prise en main
n'est pas toujours simple pour les
patients l'accompagnement d'un médecin
reste
[Musique]
essentiel alors il est essentiel mais
moi je vais vous dire quelque chose
docteur Ramon si j'ai besoin d'un
renouvellement d'ordonnan je veux bien
aller dans la cabine pour pas encombrer
vos vos cabin est-ce que vous est-ce que
renouvellement d'ordonnance c'est jamais
un renouvellement d'ordonnance c'est une
réévaluation du
traitement entendre end de parler de
renouvellement d'ordonnance c'est c'est
jamais ça un renouvellement d'ordonnance
c'est toujours une consultation vous
vous pesez les gens vous prenez
l'attention c'est l'idéal c'est l'idéal
mais c'est au lieu d'attendre pendant 6
mois un rendez-vous ine j'ai un contact
à distance qu même avec un M clairement
la téléconsultation est un bon outil
quand il est utilisé par un médecin qui
prend contact avec un infirmier qui est
au domicile du patient et à ce moment-là
on peut avoir une vraie téléexpertise
c'est un bon outil c'est un bon outil
c'est un bon outil quand on demande un
avis à un médecin spécialiste et là il
une texertise là clairement ce qu'on
voit c'est une dégradation de la qualité
de prise en charge des patients
clairement parce que l'État depuis 20
ans refuse de donner un problème refuse
de donner donner de l'attractivité à ce
métier vous avez parl salari tout à
l'heure je vous donne l'exemple de la
sonéloire la sonloire à salarié 84
médecins vous savez quel est le
rendement de ces gens qui sont payés
entre 5 et 6000 € par an par mois 27
consultations par semaine 27
consultations par semaine en étant
salari en sonire oui 300 millions de
recettes pour 84 médecins vous faites le
calcul bon mais est-ce que vous êtes
tous d'accord pour revenir sur la télé
consultation que pour vous c'est un
contreèle oou est-ce que j'aais vu il y
a un chire qui m'a frappé 80000
téléconsultations en 2019 avant le covid
bien sûr 9400000 en 2021 7/ 10 en zonees
urbaines 7/ 10 et alors quelle quelle
conclusion quelle conclusion c'est que
la télémédecine c'est un outil qui
s'adresse à des patientelles c'est une
étude de l'adresse qui sont jeunes qui
sont connectés qui sont et donc en effet
qu'on a moins de problèmes de santé et
qu'on est plus à l'aise avec le
numérique a priori c'est peut-être un
petit peu
euh en revanche pour aller vers
l'accompagnement des personnes qui sont
en pathologie chronique et C il faut il
faut du lien humain et on là on a besoin
de sortir du modèle du seul médecin
traitant qui fait tout on a besoin
d'aller sur des délégations d'actes on a
besoin d'aller sur du travail en équipe
de travailler avec des infirmières et zé
coordination zéro coordination c'est
important parce qu'on on l'a pas évoqué
encore mais une des voies d'avenir
effectivement c'est de sortir du myth du
médecin qui peut tout faire et qui
travaille beaucoup plus en équipe en
travaillant et en acceptant par exemple
de faire monter en en en en en
responsabilité quel de quel Tage doit-il
se décharger vous dites le médecin qui
peut tout faire les les les infirmières
en pratique avancé c'est une c'est une
voie qui permet effectivement au côté du
médecin et sous la responsabilité du
médecin de pouvoir
effectivement de pouvoir effectivement
confier à à des des responsabilités à à
des infirmières qui sont formé pour
çaition de
loiosition de loi médicau pour enfants
malades peuvent être remplacés ça a été
adopté par des déclarations sur
l'honneur c'est intéressant est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord alors il y a beaucoup
de choses il y a le tout ce qui est
tâche administrativ les certificats et
cetera effectivement ça c'est il faut
absolument revenir là-dessus c'est une
perte de temps incroyable par contre si
la médecine de demain c'est les
téléconsultations et cetera moi j'arrête
le métier que je fais parce que j'ai
besoin de toucher les gens les examiner
de leur parler vous les verrez toujours
vous aurez toujours des patients ça sera
pas du tout pareil et je pense que c'est
une grosse perte de sens sur le métier
par contre il y a un truc qu'on a pas
abordé c'est que le patient a un rôle
clé à jouer là-dedans et on parle pas
beaucoup de prévention on n'est pas très
bon en France he par rapport à ça il les
beaucoup de téléconsultations sur les
jeunes et cetera sont pour des réponses
d'anxiété de manque de formation
d'éducation en santé de la population de
manière globale c'estd que les gens sont
extrêmement anxieux surtout depuis le
covid ont besoin en fait d'être encore
plus assisté écoutés et accompagné ça
retombe sur le médecin traitant
forcément mais sur les autres
professionnels de santé en terme de
prévention il y a énormément de travail
à faire faire on pourrait limiter
l'accès bien sûr que oui tout ce qui est
prévention santé alimentation santé
sport santé ça a un impacte pas
forcément un instant T mais un instant T
plus un sur toutes les maladies
chroniques et cetera si je comprends
bien docteur pour résumer mais si je me
trompe vous le dites la prévention c'est
tellement important que vous êtes
d'accord pour déléguer certaines tâches
par exemple certificat médical début de
l'année scolaire pour les enfants ou le
certificat médical n'a pas de valeur V
renouvellement la délégation de tâche
elle doit se faire de manière bien
atéral est coordonné évidemment qu'il y
a des tâches qui sont qui sont à
déléguer à d'autres personnes de du
moment ça permet de faire la prévention
évidemment chaque fois qu'on a voulu
avancer dans cette voielà on s'est
heurté à des batailles sans fin enfin
rappelez-vous la bataille pour que les
les pharmaciens puissent vacciner ça a
été une bataille effectivement contre
pardon mais les syndicat de médecins qui
étaient contre les infirmières de
pratique avancé bataille contre les
syndicat médecins qui sont contre à
chaque fois qu'il y a eu la la la
volonté de dire et on va on va on va
essayer de de d'organiser des des des
équipes de de soins autour du médecin ve
dire il s'agit pas de de de mettre
marginaliser le le rôle et la place du
médecin et pourtant ça permet de faire
de la meilleure qualité un exemple dans
un centre de santé dans lequel je suis
bénévole en scène saint-is dans lequel
il y a une infirmière de pratique
avancée qui travaille au côté de médecin
elle prend des consultations de 1 heure
avec ces patient diabétique la qualité
incommensurable le suivi des patients
diabétiques et cetera c'est de la
dédication de T extrêmement efficace
avec le médecin dans le bureau d'à côté
avec des profession qui travaillent
ensemble ça c'est parce qu'on est
détaché du paiement à l'ct parce on
accepte la délégation de tâche et parce
qu'on a des structures
pluriprofessionnelles avec des des
professionnels qui travaillent ensemble
je voudrais qu'on je voudrait
généraliser ça France entière et et
imaginez le coût de ce que vous
présentez là imaginez que que moi j'ai
une infirmière en pratique avancée qui
prenne une heure avec un patient ce
serait formidable mais qui la paye et
combien vous la payez et et quel locau
vous avez vous savez docteur je voudrais
vous soumettre un autre modèle vous
allez me dire parce que c'est assez
frappant on va retourner dans la Creuse
pardon parce que c'est encore une fois
un des départements les plus concernés
par notre sujet à agin et bien là les
médecins sont pas regroupés les médecins
se succèdent et ils font des missions
d'une semaine et c'est à cette condition
là que on arrive à avoir un médecin
devant les patients reportage Marianne
[Musique]
co c'est peut-être difficile à
croire mais il est parfois plus facile
de trouver 50 médecins
se dans le village d'agin dans la Creuse
chaque semaine les généralistes se
suivent et ne se ressemblent pas c'est
une dame le médecin
aujourd'hui c'est une dame elle est très
gentille sous le regard des
coordinatrices les praticiens se rela
pour assurer l'accès au soins des
habitants de ce désert médical 1200
patients ont choisi ce centre de santé
comme médecin
traitant centre médical d'AG
bonjour
je vous je vous mets avec un autre
patient mais comme c'est une urgence
quand il y a eu une proposition de poste
de
publi euh je me suis demandé ce que
c'était c'est vrai que c'était assez
curieux et et on se lance là-dedans
parce qu'on se dit que qu'on est dans
une aventure où on est là pour aider
pour trouver des solutions surtout de
pas juste rester en se disant mince on a
rien plus de 200 généralistes se sont
eux aussi engagés dans le projet du
collectif des médecins solidaires le
planning des remplacements est plein
jusqu'en janvier 2024 pour chaque
médecin transport et logement sont pris
en charge et la rémunération est de 1000
€ net pour un contrat de 35 he mais ce
n'est pas l'aspect financier qui a
poussé le docteur Molinier à venir
assurer les consultations cette semaine
quand on voit des patients comme ce
matin qui n'avaient pas
consulté depuis plus de 2 3 ans et notre
métier c'est quand même d'aider d'aider
l'autre donc
oui
bah je je je me sens plus utile ici que
en région parisienne où j'ai aussi
exercé retraité encore actif comme le
docteur molignier ou jeune pas encore
installer les médecins de passage
doivent assurer la continuité des soins
alors la bonne tenue des dossiers
médicaux est essentielle chercheer votre
dossier alors si vous permettez on se
connaît pasou donc bah je vais faire un
tour rapide de de votre dossier pour me
mettre un petit peu dans l'affaire vous
êtes suivi pour
l'hypertension problème de
thyroïdeépidémie un diabète et vous
faites des apnés du sommeil c'est ça
j'ai besoin de voir tous les 3
mois un médecin qui soit au courant de
mon dossier et qui me qui puisse me me
renouveler mon traitement et voir
éventuellement s'il y a d'autres
problèmes qui sont survenus entretemps
l'ouverture du centre médical a été un
grand soul 2 ans après le départ à la
retraite du médecin du village les
habitants désespérent d'en trouver un
nouveau j'avais arrêé le traitement j'ai
dit j'en ai marre ensite que je CR d'un
côté ou de l'autre et heureusement que
les autres sont arrivés il m'a dit non
non faut
pas faut pas faut pas déconner avec
ça on va vous prendre en
main une personne qui tombe en panne sur
il va pas regarder qui est-ce qui va
venir le dépanner donc c'est vrai que
moi je pars de ce principe donc que je
sois soigné par un médecin traitant
toute l'année que ça soit le même ou 50
ça me dérange absolument pas du moment
que on prend le téléphone on les appelle
on a un souci ils sont là après si c'est
un annuel ou un un semaine c'est pas
grave avant de trouver cette solution
innovante la commune avait tout essayé
pour attirer un généraliste elle a même
réalisé une vidéo promotionnelle à
laquelle les commerçants du village
comme gilltier ont participé en bureau
de tabac journaux le seul problème c'est
que notre docteur qui est là depuis 40
ans il part à la retraite à la fin de
l'année des situations comme celle-ci le
docteur martial Jardel en a rencontré
beaucoup fraîchement diplômé à 30 ans il
a fait un tour de France des
remplacements dans des déserts médicaux
aujourd'hui installé il comprend très
bien pourquoi cette décision est
difficile à prendre quand on a 30 ans et
qu'on se dit que si dans 2 ans on change
le projet de vie on crée un drame humain
mais on a pas envie de créer un drame
humain donc on préfère ne pas
s'installer et donc plus il y a de
pénurie plus ça entraîne de la pénurie
parce que les médecins ont peur de
s'installer dans des territoires
où c'est uniquement eux qui tiendront la
responsabilité de l'accès au soins donc
partager cette responsabilité là c'est
un élément de réponse c'est qu'on dit au
médecin vous allez pas être responsable
d'un accès au territoire pendant 30 ans
vous allez être responsable d'un accès
aux soins du territoire pendant une
semaine c'est ainsi qu'il a eu l'idée de
fonder le collectif des médecins
solidaires aujourd'hui 200 généralistes
font partie du réseau pour s'essayer à
la médecine rurale à la fin de son
remplacement le docteur Molinier recevra
un panier garni on a une lonnette à la
mertille de la terine de quelquesuns des
meilleurs arguments de la région pour
qu'un médecin de passage s'y installe
pour de
[Musique]
bon madame r j'ai bien aimé c'est la
première phrase de ce reportage c'est
plus facile d'en trouver 50 que un seul
bon est-ce que c'est pas l'idéal
évidemment mais est-ce que c'est quand
même une solution dans les déserts
médicaux cette tribu on va dire cette
tribu de médecin qui se passe la main
c'est sûr que c'est mieux que rien comme
je disais tout à l'heure on est dans une
gestion de la pénurie après en terme de
suivi évidemment c'est moins bien que
d'avoir un suivi dans la durée sachant
que avec mon Espace Santé le fait de
centraliser tous les documents de santé
les résultats d'analyse et compagnie sur
la même plateforme ça pourrait améliorer
le suivi faute de mieux après ça serait
mieux d'avoir un système qui favorise
les installations pérennes dans les
zones les plus sous-dotées mais voilà
dans une situation où c'est pas possible
dans l'immédiat il vaut mieux ça que
rien en tout cas on voit que il y a il y
a l'imagination dans l'air on cherche
des solutions à tout crain pour essayer
de mettre des médecins devant de euh des
patients si vous aviez une mesure
docteur Crest une mesure que vous
voudriez voir aujourd'hui mise en œuvre
pour essayer de répondre je sais qu'il y
a 20 façons d'aborder la question
question tarifaire la rémunération
l'attractivité les études vous qu'est-ce
qui vous semble le plus
important c'est tellement complexe que
je peux pas vous dire une chose comme ça
moi ce que j'entends c'est que dans tous
ces conflits c'est toujours bilatéral il
y a fondamentalement un besoin d'écoute
et de comprendre pourquoi est-ce que les
syndicats de médecins ont peur de la
délégation de tâche c'est qu'il y a
peut-être une raison il y a un vrai
problème de reconnaissance et de respect
mutuel que ce soit de la part des
patients sur les rendez-vous non honorés
que ça soit la part des médecins sur le
temps passé et la qualité donné il y a
beaucoup des rendez-vous non honorés par
non mais pour vous par exemple oui il y
en a mais mois parce que je suis
extrêmement j'essaie d'être d'avoir une
autorité douce sur mes patients et de
leur expliquer pourquoi moi ça ça ça me
ça me crée du tort ça me fait même du
mal en fait de dire d'avoir du temps où
je pourrais accueillir quelqu'un et que
ce temps est perdu si j'ai un prends
rendez-vous et je ne viens pas vous ne
me reprenez pas la prochaine fois non
peut-être pas la première fois mais la
deuxième fois en tout cas je vous
explique si je crois fondamentalement
dans dans l'éducation et le fait que les
gens doivent comprendre comment ça peut
se passer ensemble sinon ça marchera pas
et des deux côtés il y a une souffrance
et cette souffrance si on essaie pas de
la comprendre au sens communication non
violente compréhension sociétale
psychologique on y arrivera pas moi je
suis je suis
vraiment pour ce pour ce ce modèle là de
d'écoute vraiment parce que sinon sinon
on n'avancera pas et on rappelle que
vous présentez votre rapport on
connaîtra les mesures en décembre sur
l'amélioration de la santé des soignants
parce que les soignants ils soignent
mais ils ont aussi besoin d'être soignés
AR bontan on a un enjeu de réponse aux
maladies chroniques qui se développe de
réponse à au l'enjeu de qualité de
travail des professionnels de santé et
eux-mêmes sont pris dans des injonctions
contradictoires cell notamment porté par
le modèle de rémunération s'il y avait
une chose je pense qu'il faudrait qu'on
ait le courage de s'attaquer à ça euh
les négociations on a eu il y a pas si
longtemps une grève des profess de de
certains professionnels de santé
concentré autour du tarif de la
consultation le le tarif de la tâche en
fait il faut qu'on sorte de cette
question 26,50 € 26 50 30 on entendait
50 ce n'est pas la bonne question la
question c'est comment est-ce qu'on a un
modèle de rémunération qui permet la
coordination qui permet la prise en soin
des patients les plus complexes qui
permet le travail en équipe et pour ça
on a besoin de sortir du paiement à la
tâche et ça tout le monde s'en sorti
grandi les patients qui aur meilleure
qualité de soins les professionnels qui
auront une meilleure qualité de travail
le système de santé qui pourra prendre
du avec du temps supérieur pris pour la
prévention pourra avancer vers le défi
des maladies chroniques docteur Amond
une mesure donner les moyens à la ville
d'éviter les hospitalisations et de les
raccourcir s'appuyer sur les équipes de
soins primaires supprimer les
prestataires à la sortie de l'hôpital
qui bouffent la laine sur le dos des
pharmaciens et des infirmières libérales
et et ça leur donnera pas envie de ça
leur donnera envie de pas changer de
métier faire en sorte que les moyens ont
les ça puisque j'ai appris au compte de
la santé que l'État avait piqué 8
milliards dans la cadesse la cadesse qui
un impôt qui rapporte 23 milliards 8
milliards depuis 3 ans pour investir à
l'hôpital qu'on investisse ces 8
milliards sur la ville une
année mes la
mesure faut avoir les moyens il faut
avoir les moyens fa avir la volonté
certainement pas des rustines comme
C présenter aux
élection pardon vousad ça va venir
peut-être qu'on va faire des list euré
parole à votre voisine moi je dis
réguler l'installation comme ce qui se
fait pour les pharmaciens comme ce qui
se fait depuis cet été pour les
dentistes ce qui était déjà le cas pour
les infirmières les kinés en fait il ne
reste plus que les médecins pour
lesquels l'installation n'est pas
régulée et madame cresgilui vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que les vocation
searissait si je me souviens bien lors
de la dernière promo il y a 60 % des
étudiants qui ont validé leur première
année qui n'ont pas été admis en 2e
année de médecine donc moi dans les
chiffres je le vois pas le tarissement
d'é voocation donc pour moi il faut donc
réguler l'installation et aussi
augmenter les capacités des facs de pour
pouvoir former davantage de médecins à
l'aveniréric Valtou moi je crois
profondément à la capacité des soignants
à partir du moment où ils travaillent
ensemble à inventer des modes de prise
en charge so différents d'un territoire
à l'autre et donc il faut arriver à la
fois à décloisonner c'est dire à sortir
de ce face à face la médecine
hospitalière la médecine libérale le
généraliste le spécialiste le médecin le
pasmédecin l'infirmière et cetera pour
arriver à ce que ça soit beaucoup plus
fluide et pour ça il faut leur faire
confiance il faut peut-être
effectivement qu'on sorte d'un d'un
système qui fasse plus confiance aux
initiatives de terrain et au mode de
prise en charge qui soit décidé
elle-même par les équipes soignantes
c'estàdire que on soit moins prescriptif
au niveau national un système très
jacobin très encadré et que laisser
l'initiative au terrain laiss
l'initiative au terrain que loi essayer
de faire pour avancer une faire porter
une nouvelle étape dans cette voie pour
conclure sur une n j'espère pas trop
grave Docteur CR juste guérir en mer
c'est une association qui accompagne les
soignants qui sont victimes de Burnout
ça consiste en quoi c'est aussi de la
prévention et de l'accompagnement de
l'épuisement professionnel des soignants
toute profession du soin confondu
justement on décloisonne c'est pas que
des médecins c'est tout le monde et vont
fait quoi on va faire du bateau le
bateau c'est un sport santé absolument
incroyable et en fait le les parallèles
entre la voile et la santé sont énormes
gestion des émotions travail en équipe
mais à la fois moment de solitude
intense sport environnement naturel
travail d'équipe et en fait on voit que
quand on est soignant s'adapte très bien
sur un bateau vice-va on peut s'inspirer
de ce qui se passe en mer pour le
ramener dans son en milieu professionnel
ça recrée du lien entre les soigneurs
qui manqu fondamentalement de
communication entre eux ça donne
confiance ça revalorise on a une tâche
on est capable de la faire et sur un
bateau en fait on peut laisser personne
de côté on peut pascheter à la mer
quelqu'un on est obligé d'avancer
ensemble voilà alors évidemment en creux
c'est compliqué mais il y a des rivières
et il y a des il y a aussi des lacs lac
de vasivière puisque vous êtes allé à
Royer de vassivère il y a pas longtemps
merci infiniment et j'imagine qu'on peut
trouver votre association si besoin si
on est sur bord d'un littoral euh sur
sur Internet merci beaucoup
merci infiniment à bonemps merci
Frédéric Valtou madame R et docteur Amon
toujours aussi passionné c'est la fin de
cette émission d'état de santé consacré
à au médecins généraliste à très vite et
à bientôt sur
[Musique]
LCP